i have lost about
probably 15 to 25 of my people i grew up
with
all of them got killed for different
reasons just wrong place wrong time
both of my parents was incarcerated by
the time i was two
my mom was locked up for forgery and my
father was locked up for bank robbers
my father had a
10 to 30 sentence my mother had
10 years in the feds
my mother ended up going back to jail
for a year but she gave me a little
brother before she went back
and i ended up raising my little brother
god be told i lost him when he was 18.
people killed him man
he broke the crap game up and he killed
him
it took a lot of years for that pain to
leave and
for me to find some peace
[Music]
our data is really showing that a lot of
these just petty arguments just not
being able to process anger is leading
to a lot of the homicides that we've
been seeing
i had an associate he was a real cool
dude at one time man we was really
really tight
a person was jealous of them
i could not believe
they killed him
my little brother you know situation
with the dudes was his friend wasn't
getting along with their people so it's
just a lot of different reasons why
somebody ended up pulling out that gun
we're talking about people who have lost
hope
people who are
at risk
deeply traumatized and have also run out
of options
i know why people get killed the number
one reason is
power people want to feel empowered
people want to feel strong and all it
takes is
meet up with somebody to feel that way
and you feel that way
somebody's going to die somebody going
to jail so obviously both of y'all lose
in the end
one of the strongest predictors
that
someone will become involved in gun
violence is being close to someone else
who's involved in gun violence so if you
know a shooter if you're friends with a
victim you're at increasingly higher
risk
when you try to
explain a jealousy that'll give a person
a reason to kill another man
it's really not even in words mind
the pain or the
envy or the i want to say destruction
man that some people put in their heads
i can't sit here and say it without
telling myself that i used to think like
that
one crew will have a rapper that that
disparages another crew and then that
becomes we have to stand up for
ourselves they're not going to stand up
to it and rap back like we may have had
several years ago now it's okay you've
offended me i'm going to the gun
have you ever hated somebody you ever
thought about hurting them
never to extend what you wanted to take
somebody like
the pandemic has influenced
the transactional nature that human
beings are having right now across the
board
a lot of what you would see before as
word beefs be taken out much more in the
realm of gunplay
petty insults could be a problem but i
believe there's probably
more
envious and jealousy and disrespecting
each other
we never know somebody to be jealous of
that person not because they the star
basketball player or they drive the
biggest car in the school
no they just jealous of you they don't
like nothing about you
just below half of the violence that
we're seeing is only in about 151 blocks
in the city
when we
look at who is actually involved in
these incidents as victims or suspects a
substantial portion of those individuals
our group and gang involved
even though
a grouper gang dispute isn't at the
heart of that incident
dc
doesn't really have a problem with the
big games like bloods or the crips but
they do have these
local kind of neighborhood turf gangs
probably
mid-20s
of the ones that are truly active some
of it is a drug game thing but a lot of
it's not it's a lot of it's just this is
my crew this is my area
it goes back to their grandfather for
folks like you and i is on fathom rule
but it's not in our in our community
right now
stop when we kids i think all kids got
it when you're in the right home when
you're in the right environment you get
taught what's right and what's wrong but
when you're not in that right
environment when you're not in that
right community when you when your
mother and father hate people just as
much as you do that grow in you
and i come out
a lot of times in that night with that
gun
you